[Applause]
all right last three rows of challenged
officers to a 12-hour holiday in ivory
Ferb we've got challenges and activities
that they've given us to do while we're
over there
the one catch is they left you back in
the office and 9:00 a.m. tomorrow can't
wait
[Music]
we're getting on that plane to IB food
let's go away now we're a hobby for
pretty muggy be honest with you baby our
short song mighty bring some sauce
Lankan are some girls like ya Tim pretty
sure setup didn't bring short so I be
I hope it is challenge number one find a
swimming pool and cannonball into it
Oh may can you take those to the nearest
ER importance mate
[Music]
there's that done next challenge what's
up
challenge number two former human
pyramid on the beach and climb to the
top are you gonna do that
just makes a mate Scotland yeah yeah
sure yeah
the original plumbers gathered up but
we're gonna get on the bottom because I
we're not the smaller select start a
dancer DUI
well I can't I was
[Music]
we
[Music]
right we have just done every single
challenge in stereo set for us so now
we're gonna see if we can effectively or
not am looking all right so far early
yeah but we haven't finished here
I'm absolutely
[Music]
something out from 2010 things about our
past is corset or chef Dakota Alan's
Uribe at 15 minutes maybe we are
codified and we're gonna have to run
which have to roll is it righteous right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]